when I first moved to LA Signs and all
the doors said no actors or dogs allowed
I changed that but I hate that yeah it'd
be a little scary oh my God there's no
way to get it right
um you I'll tell you what if you if
there was a good director good writer
and director like this cat here oh you
can do mine I could do the brap yeah you
can store it yeah no seriously because
it's a lot of responsibility when you're
taking on a real-life person and
but it takes a great Direction y'all
ready for something different and to
make it right you would have to include
the story of his lucky break my big one
was was Ridley Scott and Gina Tina Davis
giving me a shot and filming Louise that
that that pretty much opened the door
you're
that cause that no I'm sorry no you're
okay and one of the signs of a great
actor Crying On Cue
no solid effort Brad but before his big
break the most famous actor in the world
had to hustle many odd jobs one of them
was driving strippers to their parties
and really yeah yeah your early days I
still had a mullet and uh early days
[Music]